yeah
Jamie erdog if you're able to take it
away
[Applause]
yeah throw in let me go find quotes here
he's finding his family right now
coach coach
we're gonna go find a camera come here
all right on Wednesday we heard you say
in the locker room the more I watch
Purdue the more I think I can beat this
we can beat this team what did you see
on tape well I mean I just trust our
guys I have faith in our guys that
speech got overblown you know we just
have faith in what we do and our guys
are so tough and so competitive you know
I'll do a better job in this locker room
speech than the last one I'll be a
little more good but it was the right
message maybe the wrong audience but
listen I love our guys they're tough
they're gritty there they play their
tails off that's an unbelievable win I
mean we just did something there was
something that's unbelievable we just
shocked the world and and uh couldn't
happen to a better for a bunch of guys a
better bunch of fans but family the
whole thing so we are ecstatic
unbelievable we're gonna stay in
Columbus I love it
you are a kid from Iowa you're cut your
dad was a coach you coached at D3 D2 D1
how proud do you think your dad is of
you tonight oh man
don't make me cry
I wish he was here man wish you could
see what's going on here I mean most of
your life division three division two
you're in front of 100 people family and
friends we're in front of 20 000 people
here in front of the whole world just
beat Purdue I mean and all my stuff
comes from him my dad was a much better
Coach than I was but I've got a better
team than he had so it makes a lot of it
makes a lot easier but no I wish he was
here with my mom was here but we got a
great family and friends and I'm so
proud of this team and what a wonderful
thing this is I'm just it's incredible
and our team I couldn't be happy this
place going after you after you it's
just it's just awesome it's awesome
congratulations thank you so much
unbelievable scene here in Columbus
as fdu a team that won four games a year
ago knocks out a Purdue team
that went 29 and five
let's go back to Jamie I'm with the
hometown kid from Columbus Ohio Sean
what did you just feel when you went to
go greet your family man I felt amazing
because I didn't really think was going
to be here at this point of the Season
man just felt great to get this dog show
people that we could be here and people
ain't thinking we belong to be here
we're just showing people that we could
do what we could do in this tournament
with the big dog so we doing great right
now on to the next dub man Sean you had
45 points in the regular season you had
19 tonight what came into you man I just
I'm just trying to do whatever I could
do to help my team win so it is you know
surviving events man that's the best
thing I could do for my team and just
help my team win so yeah you just be the
number one team ranked in the bracket
when did you know you could do it two I
ain't gonna lie I'm gonna say the
Louisville Chicago game that was a
that's a very big team you know they go
to the NCAA tournament almost every year
for the past couple years we played a
very tough game that game even though
the guys on the buzzer but ever since
that game I knew that we could come
where we at right now you followed your
head coach Tobin Anderson to this school
because does that feel like the best
decision you've ever made tonight oh
yeah for sure he believed him he says
day one a lot of a lot of college
coaches slept on me in my recruiting but
he was on me I know he believed in me so
I'll follow him you see where I'm at now
so he believed in his players and so is
me so yeah congratulations thank you
Jamie they're dancing in Teaneck New
Jersey
unbelievable